the first thing i want to say
is i want to say our hearts of this
community go out
to the victims of this horrific incident
we know of 10 fatalities
at the scene including one of our
boulder pd officers by the name of eric
talley who's been on the boulder police
department
since 2010 he served in
numerous roles supporting the boulder
police department
and the community of boulder and i have
to tell you
the heroic action of this officer when
he responded to this scene
at 14 30 hours the boulder police
department began receiving
phone calls of shots fired
in the area and a phone call about a
possible person
with a patrol rifle officer tally
responded to the scene was the first on
the scene
and he was fatally shot i also want to
commend
the heroic actions of the officers
responding not only from boulder pd
but from across the county and other
parts
of this region
police officers actions felt nothing
short of being heroic
i also want to thank the men and women
who responded
including state local and federal
authorities
obviously this is a very complex
investigation
that will take no less than five days to
complete
and again my heart
goes out to the victims of this
incident and i'm grateful
for the police officers that responded
and i am so sorry
about the loss of officer talley
and again we will be here working night
and day
we have one suspect in custody i want to
reassure the community that they are
safe
and that we will try to do our best over
the next
few hours to identify the victims
and we'll be working with the coroner's
office to do that as promptly as
possible
because i know there are people out
there waiting for an answer
and i am very sympathetic to that and we
will work around the clock to get this
accomplished
with that in mind i'm going to turn this
over to district eternity michael
dougherty